yeah oh yeah yeah it sure is time
okay so um
yeah i know i know it's a big data done
for all of you um
let me just close this down um so it's a
totally different sort of
flavor in a way um so it's really
strange you know
i guess this always happens you know so
because i was thinking about this for a
long time
starting in january
um i've been sort of trying to think
about how to present all this stuff
to real newcomers you know i said no so
no markov stuff
keep things simple sine waves instead of
noise
and instead of trying to prepare this i
had a really cool discovery
in the last six weeks so this wasn't
supposed to be research
seminar this is supposed to be a
tutorial
um so that's why you'll see an emergency
exit sign if if i'm going too far
i'll just tips and slides
and i won't give the details but there's
something in here i'm super excited
about
um and then i'm going to give more
applications so the first hour
is going to be sort of some general
theory um
with with applications and all and the
second one will be more
applications and history oriented and
and a full history of active critics
six 1968 okay
um so first of all you know i've been
talking about suggested approximation i
want to define it
i'll do that one slide uh i want to
explain to you what i mean by
quasi-strategist
approximation i've already said it i'm
replacing noise by
by quasi random numbers like sine waves
and i've learned over the last four
months that the area of quasi-monte
carlo is so
damned hard it is so deep and so
difficult
i'm not going to touch that theory i'll
talk about sine waves just to make it
easy
and i'm going to explain how you apply
this to grading free optimization
and just so i'll be getting closer to
critic methods
all right and i'll show some examples
and then this is the thing i'm really
excited about
but i think it may be too much so adithy
says sean it's too much
we'll see okay i'll give you the result
i might not give you the proof
all right so um a lot of i mean so
the paper i mentioned with brashant on
um
lp methods for q learning um
that goes back you know quite a ways
when i was at
nrl two years ago uh i got a big
i just a fantastic interaction with
people there you know
including um andre you you'll hear from
at the end of today marchella who's went
back to eth who's at eth
and emiliano who's at boulder colorado
and i'm sorry for the crappy photograph
uh that's the uhn during his graduation
several years ago he's a dandruff now
and that's juan chen who's uh in the
math department here he'll be graduating
by the way this guy is awesome they'll
be graduating
uh next year so keep your eyes open
um so stochastic approximation by
caricature is this
you you know throw in a bunch of noise
in stochastic
in q in reinforcement learning it's
often excitation
um or exploration uh and you get some
estimates of some parameter theta n
which determines your q function your
policy or something like that
and this is going back to eric's comment
that asymptotic statistics are useful um
you know basically aditya's thesis a lot
of it was about
using the central limit theorem which is
an asymptotic concept a stochastic
approximation
for algorithm design and it was very
successful for the algorithms he's
looking at
it's not doesn't always work but it did
in his case
all right so the goal is that we've
talked about
every single problem we've talked about
is a root finding problem
we want to find a solution f bar of
theta star equals zero
where the f bar
is a function of a parameter theta
and something random that comes from
nature or on
exploration signals or whatever so
that's what sarcastic approximation is
and and just like eric
i have a million different symbols for
the same thing i've
theta i've got a little squiggly theta
i've got a big theta
i've got so many thetas it's insane um
it's just
there are enough symbols in the world um
but so
this is what i mean chaba about it being
backwards
why did robinson monroe present an
algorithm
and then i don't know that make it clear
that
the entire algorithm was this
the whole algorithm was we would like an
od to
to um solve the suit finding problem
right maybe we've designed the root
finding problem
so this od is stable and then let's use
an euler scheme
to approximate that i'm more talking
about pedagogy i don't know why
it's always flipped around we present an
algorithm and then we analyze it
so often the od comes first
but it's not just pedagogy you'll see
so again you would do an euler
approximation if you could
right it involves an expectation that's
too
complex and so what you do is you
replace the f bar
which is too complex to compute with the
observations
right that's that's the definition of
stochastic approximation
and and basically the idea is
you can write this down as
exactly this
but with noise and so all of the
convergence their stochastic
approximation
is to say that um i should have
waited that euler approximations are
robust
that's conversion states to caster
approximation and
it is robust and it takes a bit of
muscle
to prove that robustness but that's it
that's what stochastic approximation is
so i don't know why
it's made out to be so mysterious um
it's really funny and i think that
uh it's a disservice because it's a very
beautiful and powerful technique
and it's a shame that intimidates people
so much but that's it
you have an od you like to approximate
you can't do euler
so you basically do a noisy euler
approximation
um and the thing is that oil
approximations are robust
and the mathematical tools used to prove
that are the same you use
to prove that this is conversion the
theory is identical
identical you know i know that i know
there's a bit of martingale stuff in
there
but those that's just properties of the
disturbance
yeah you know there's bellman god well
you know how much noise is there
and dumb and grand well done here the
noise
is because you're discretizing an ode
is there a more precise way of saying
that these are identical
or deter the theories the series
identity bellman gronwall is the key
step
okay
so so basically to prove existence to
the ode
bell and grandma you know um to prove
that this thing approximates this thing
film and grown wall and the here dealing
with the noise you get narrator and
belmont grown wall so
you know and so that's why if you look
at the exact borkhart's book
he knocks off convergence just in a you
know very quickly in a paragraph in one
subsection and then moves on
so the convergence theory is not deep
it just took a lot of brilliant people
to come up with the right way of setting
up the problem for analysis
and now that it's so well done it's
really easy to understand convergence
theory
now grades of convergence theory is
still deep and difficult
and when when this function is nasty if
it's not lipschitz or something
then that that's when you get huge
literature like work of that name and
stuff
uh you can see references in the uh at
the end
okay now that's convergence theory
um um so you can see
cvx monograph um now
um oh yeah i didn't i thought it was
slide but but again rates of convergence
variance all that stuff that's when the
statistics really comes in
and then things really get harder now um
let me let me you know let me
work towards it closer to convince you
that this is how the od method should be
defined
is that first you design the dynamics
so that theta t converges to the
desired theta star you have to decide
what your theta star should be
your metric should be and so therefore
this converges convergence holds as well
so this is a control problem right
it's regulation
you know we're trying to make theta t
the state variable
converge to a a desired equilibrium
theta star
it's a control problem but there's no
physics
we are unbound by nature any kind of
laws we can do whatever we want
so for example here's something crazy
let's forget about thinking of theta t
as a variable
you know why not think of f bar of theta
t as a variable
you know this would say that uh f
bar of theta t is just equal to
f bar of theta zero times e to the minus
t
happy face right
yeah we could do whatever we want now
this is going to be complex
because when you do the chain rule
you'll get a matrix gain algorithm
but that's one way now we know how you
derive you're learning
and it's called the newton-raphson flow
now that's that's what i mean
smail this is from smail back in the 70s
well i'm just trying to get it we have
so much freedom in designing the ode
and then we have to talk to a numerical
analyst perhaps to find out the most
efficient way to approximate it
and they might they might suggest some
kuta method instead of a
lagrange all right all right
so this is one example for the od design
you'd never find this in a discrete
world
you'd only find it by thinking about
ease
okay so i'm pulling you a little to my
side now of course i'm not saying it's
the only way to do things but i
i'm saying that that this is an example
where the od gives you great insight in
how to design an algorithm
yeah the translation yeah so in this
problem definition uh what is hidden is
that
very often you have constraints on what
you're observing
so it's true that you want to control
theta in some way
and then there are some constraints on
what you are observing and then you have
to cook with that
and somehow apply things such that you
get on one hand stability
and on the other hand you're only
working with things that you can observe
so the way you're writing these two
things match up but
if i'm thinking about just td learning
or something like that
there are a million ways of constructing
these things and
you know you can change uh various
things
yeah that's right well if you're
objective
if i identify an objective which is f
bar of theta
star equals zero right
you know if that's your goal right
then you have a control problem and you
and to solve that control problem
you know you want it you want to design
a stable ode
you know as i said that's a control
problem
that's what i mean so if you if you've
been given a goal
written as an expectation
you know then you want to think really
hard about od design
yeah i i totally agree i'm just making
the note that
uh there is some observer um
process also going on here absolutely
that's what i
that's why i highlighted this i mean
right there yeah yeah right we're
assuming that we were
getting imported
yeah but sometimes that's not so simple
yeah okay
anyways yeah oh no i'm not i'm not
saying this is the only way to think
about things please please please
i'm you know i'm kind of object i just
think that lenny jung made a big mistake
way back when i think it would be much
prettier
teaching this to spend a lot more time
on odes
understand the stability properties and
then say hey there's numerical methods
to approximate
and hey this even numerical methods
when you don't observe the uh functions
it's just
i'm thinking more pedagogy than anything
yeah
um putting up a terrorist hat
uh the natural question to ask is
whether
if you're thinking in terms of designs
that can come out from this
is this going to be limited in some way
i are we ruling out
uh any discrete time arguments
absolutely
absolutely so we're all the the um
the batch algorithms i talked about in
lecture two you know no way
you know it's just all they then you
have to go backwards you know you you
design the linear program
and then you can prove convergence
through node e that's the case where
lenny lung is absolutely right
you know i have to store that algorithm
yeah the real question is whether we're
losing anything
uh in terms of this example
yes there they're examples where we are
where you where this is it's not it's
too restrictive
absolutely okay okay
it's not the only one okay
yeah but again but let me just say it
again to everybody you would you would
never get
my previous talk from od methods you
really need
uh to think discrete and then and then
and then
use the od methods it's easily defined
for stability
okay um now the uh
the next thing is you can start looking
at gain selection
and and there's some really pretty
theory there so
if you take a gain which is
a step size which is some constant times
n plus one then you can get this optimal
one over n convergence rate
for the mean square error but only
if this matrix is horowitz
where a star is a linearization assuming
it's
it's smooth uh at the equilibrium um
which is a sad fact
that's a sad phase so you need
you need g big enough
yeah just for clarification whoever it's
means that
eigenvalues lie in the left open plane
thank you some people sometimes flip
these things
but i know i'm sorry so uh yeah so i i
mean
that means all the eigenvalues
are over here in the left half plane
yeah
yeah thank you thank you thank you i
forgot i forgot to mention that
so the um yeah um
yeah so that basically the linearization
is asymptotically stable
uh um at the end and so that that's a
sad fact you know
and so the and the the zap things i
mentioned was a way to deal with that
and to get optimal convergence right i
mean to optimize the constant
okay and when that happens you actually
have a formula
and again i don't i don't want to keep
on harking back to um
to eric but i just it's nice to get
somebody else to say it
asymptotic statistics can be valuable um
and i'm not i don't have time to show
you plots
but the clt is sometimes very very
rapid to converge and so you can get
real insight on
rates and conversions in the asymptotic
statistics and
isn't it amazing that only
linearizations are enough
to tell you about the optimal rate of
convergence
you don't need to know the covariance of
the noise
to know if the rate of convergence is
optimal
you know it's all about sort of you know
very very uh um
you know really simple concepts um so
it's
i i love this stuff but i can i can give
you examples not today but where
it does fail where the clt is worthless
i can i can
give examples numerical examples all
right
so there it is you know everything about
stochastic approximation i mean
i just wanted to explain what it is and
there's a nice theory
now i want to do the whole thing over
again with sine waves instead of noise
all right and you see i've got these
pretty sine waves
you know and now i've got my estimates
going along in this beautiful smooth way
well
i claim this is reality and all the
examples i've looked at it's
it's so pretty how using the smooth
exploration how how cool it looks but i
haven't looked at high dimensional
problems yet so
all right so all right you ready for
your crash course
questions
all right um so in a lot of applications
we create the noise now i know that's
not universal
not finance
but you know in many applications the
volatility is not the biggest issue
there's
there's randomness and uncertainty um
and there's
you know there's randomness but it's
complexity and uncertainty about the
model
things like that that drive everything
and we definitely create
i think most of you would agree in the
numerical work you've done
the us creating the noise is the biggest
source of noise
when google spent 47 days training their
computer to play chess they inserted the
noise
the chest wasn't being noisy okay
so if we're considering the noise then
we might as well make it
tame might as well make it nice
okay um and why settle for this crappy
rate of convergence
we're getting this lousy rate of
convergence because we're introducing
this
this blah noise let's stop
it's a terrible rate of convergence so
what we want is to get
that rate of convergence instead of one
over n
we want one over n squared and maybe we
want to
optimize the constant as well and do it
purely deterministically
so there's an expectation there which
i'll explain there's still expectations
um and then go through this three-step
design process so
basically i want to design an od based
on my goal
as i said before then i'm going to
you know come up with something based on
exploration
and then i'm going to use something like
euler or some other
better approximation to go from the ode
to this
trying to preserve so i'm going to get
really tight beautiful results
on the rate of conversion to this result
so that's brand new
it's a month old um and then i need a
numerical analyst
to tell me how to the best way to
preserve that rate
rather than reproduce the theory here i
think i can just be very clever in my
numerical approximation
and how to sample this to get to
preserve my rate of convergence
right that's a conjecture you know so
i'll write that down that's a conjecture
the conjecture is can i preserve waves
that's not called that's what i mean my
conjecture is that we can preserve the
rates
um that's an open question all right
ready
okay so um
all right everybody drink your
cappuccino your espresso
you know um i've gotta i've gotta do
some technicalities
put into technology so an example of a
of this quasi noise is just sinusoids
but it's much easier to work with
complex exponentials
okay so i've got a bunch a vector of
complex exponentials of
of different frequencies okay and that's
just an example
of where i get this crucial property
that i need for rates of convergence
that if i take this noise and i do look
at partial integrals
they're bounded because they're also
just sine waves
okay now we're going to see that that's
a very general property
for dynamical systems as i'll explain
so what i'm going to do is to generalize
these um
this complex exponentials i'm going to
assume my noise comes out of a dynamical
system
like this because this includes all
sorts of other things like
sawtooth functions and stuff like that
[Music]
which i can make into a continuous
domain so i've got
a domain that the probing called a
probing signal lives on
uh which is compact and i've got this
vector field
h which defines c but if you like just
ignore that and just say i'm looking at
sine waves
all right so if you like the whole
lecture i'm just talking about mixed use
of sine waves
um and cosine waves because that's all
i'm doing is encoding
cosines and sine waves so wait so is
is h an operator here oh no
i know i know it's not what you'd
normally call a markov process
now but it's really important to keep in
mind that it is markov because
poisson's equation plays a major role
which is um which is something that
has followed me around my whole life and
it comes up at your credit methods it
comes up everywhere
i'll explain what i mean by that in a
moment um
[Music]
but the mindset of saying hey that's a
markov process
is really valuable in thinking about how
to analyze these algorithms
okay okay
so um there's a notion of ergodicity um
we're going to assume it's a unique
invariant measure
i apologize again denoted pi
i'm sorry i'm torturing you but pi for
me is an invariant measure
and i would assume that the sample path
averages converge
to a an ergodic average for every um
say bound to continuous function and
every initial condition
okay so this is obviously true for this
right where the limiting measure would
be product form it'd be uh
you know independent marginal's uniform
on the unit circle
in the complex plane all right
so that's my key assumption and again
just assume that if you're if you want
oh yeah poisson's equation so this is
the definition of poisson's equation
um you'd have a conditional expectation
if this was a stochastic setting but
because it's deterministic there's no
conditional expectation
so this is the definition of poisson's
equation
where g is called the forcing function
and again i spent half of my life being
chased around
by boissan's equation it's like a
terminal disease
i caught it in 1990 and i will die with
it
it just it chases me everywhere i go who
would think poisson's equation would
come up
in getting convergence rates for
deterministic algorithms well it does
um so this is crucial and you can see
the reason it's crucial
is that very often this has a very
nicely behaved solution and you can see
if it does have a solution i have an
ergodic theorem
and a rate of convergence and i got that
because i can divide both sides by t1
minus 20.
do i have it here yeah
i'm just saying here that i can divide
both sides by t
you know one over t integral zero to t
of g of c t d t
is just equal to you know g bar
and i'm taking t naught equals zero and
t
one equals t and then something divided
by t
all right i'm not going to put this in i
might make a mistake
um but um you can see it and basically
you know taking two values and making
the difference so i i i
have this optimal rate of convergence
right away right
so it turns out in order to be able to
present these results
i have to say i assume a solution of
poisson's equation exists
again it's trivial for exponentials the
conditions are just
nothing you know and i won't get into
that but
yeah you can find conditions in the
lecture notes
and then nothing so i'm going to do is
i'm i know i might not have time to say
anything about theory
so instead i'm just going to go and
present
some applications and at this time say a
few words about the theory
but this is my standing assumption that
my probing noise is a solution to a
dynamical system like this or just
complex exponentials
and i'm going to need these solutions to
poisson's equation for analysis i don't
need to compute anything
but to get right to convergence i'll
need need these guys
okay so this is gonna be fun
so um yeah this is really
this is amazing actually so um by the
way this blue thing is going to be
so great sutton's mountain car we'll get
back to the next lecture
um so suppose our objective
is to minimize some loss function l of
theta
okay and but we don't have access to
gradients so there's the kefir wall
switch
procedure which is well known in rl
circles
which is where you take finite
differences you know
um so so w here is some
typically it's assumed to be iid as it
was in
in the keyframe well for its paper and
um
and you might stick a gain in here g is
a matrix
called a gain um and
um and then and i'm not following my
rule i'm not giving you an od
and then approximating it here's an
example where you really can't
well you know i mean at least it
wouldn't be
well you could it wouldn't be it would
be very contrived
this is an example where you start to
screen analysis continuous
makes perfect sense okay
um and so to justify this it's just
taylor series expansion right i mean for
those who haven't seen it
you've got a difference of two functions
here and i've just
abstracted it a little bit and you do a
taylor series expansion of both terms
you know assuming epsilon is small and
all the even terms in the taylor series
expansion cancel out
right so you get
you get the first order term which is
the gradient
and you'd get this awful tensor looking
thing involving the
the third derivative and something
little o of
of epsilon cubed assuming you have a
uh ellipse it's a third derivative i
mean if you
have less smoothness you'll get a less
tight approximation
but right there you can see what's
happening is the gradient pops out
and what you'd like to do then is get
rid of the w and you do that through
multiplication by w
all right because you get a w times a w
and then you say you know and then
everything nice things happen as we'll
see
um so now i will write down an ode
if i take the expectation of both sides
you know we all you all know f bar means
expectation
um so then so using the standard
notion of ode method i have a discrete
time algorithm
and i look at the mean dynamics that's
the standard way people
use the term od method and you find that
this
function f bar is truly the gradient
um but you know with a the matrix g that
we introduced
and the covariance of the noise w
and again that's because i have a w
times a w so i end up with a covariance
of the noise
or if it does have zero mean it's just
the uh the uh
article um autocorrelation
um and then this all this other stuff
just becomes some
big of epsilon squared term um
or better okay all right so that's it
now there's something a lot of you don't
know about and that's
this beautiful theory of extreme seeking
control
um i don't think i'm not doing it today
am i now so i'm going to give you a full
history of this in the next
lecture comparing this and ectocritic
methods
um but it's completely wild so this
this started they claim in 1922
i'll explain that later but what you do
is you again you try to get an
approximate gradient
and here's the procedure which i will
not justify it's too hard right now
but you have a physical system and what
you do is you take your current
parameter estimate
here theta okay
and you add on a probing signal
all right like this mixture of sine
waves
so nothing's complex here a mixture of
sideways is fine
and you give it a name then you put that
in your physical system and out comes
um uh the loss evaluated that
so this this mapping
has filter like differentiation is an
example
and you put your probing signal the same
high-pass filter
and you multiply them together and that
gives you this approximate gradient
you know and then you multiply that by g
and you pass it to this
uh this machine and you get this ode
so this is this has been studied for
100 years i mean it only became
seriously studied of course in the last
50 years
but it's really old and i don't know why
it's not even well known in the controls
community
you know it's a niche sub-area of the
controls community
but they improve with a low-pass filter
which is like rupert poliak averaging so
they
they they sort of have their own rupee
poliox theory
in parallel with the stochastic world
it's it's quite remarkable
okay so um that's something there's
references
in the lecture notes okay all right
and then there's this uh quasi-kiefer
also wits
stochastic rating descent um or you just
copy and paste
all right i've i've done nothing here
you know
all i've done is i've taken the w
you see there and i've replaced it by a
sine wave for some mixture sine waves
that's all i've done so let's try it out
okay and see what happens right
so it turns out that so nothing
you know proposing this algorithm is
nothing
but it turns out you can get really
crisp rates of convergence
and and chavo i mean really understand
exactly when the i mean
i mean you'll see you'll be you'll be
surprised really
incredibly tight results on the radio
convergence
um and those are that hasn't been
published yet
and so it's summarized in the book
chapter
all right okay
all right so so next lecture i'm going
to give
examples in detail applications to
reinforcement learning here
i'm really just going to polish up you
know present
a hinted theory and go to questions
all right
okay and so in terms of rates you know
there's a hint
so there's a gain oh yeah i mean there's
a gain there you know
and the the assumption i'm going to be
making to get convergence rates
i'm going to assume that 80 goes to zero
that's really about it
for my uh my my step size so i don't
have these complicated
i don't have the set of rules you see
the stogastic approximation
all right so what do i do everybody
um i don't i'm not filled with this
this choice of step size
because i'm still forced to look at this
y plus g a star being hurwitz
to get the optimal rate
so and to see that
you only have to look at the
non-quasi stochastic approximation
algorithm just look at the thing
without noise suppose you could actually
run that od
you can't because you don't know f-bar
you don't have access to it
even even without noise
if you want a g over one plus two
greater convergence
you need this matrix to be heroids so
maybe we shouldn't use that
game that's step size rule you know it's
just uh
it's too ugly and do you see the
emergency exit button
so who wants me to talk about the theory
i i guess i'll do it until somebody
screams
okay i can't hit this i realize because
it's a it's all the good notes so i
can't even use this
um okay so here's here's a fun thing so
step one in analysis is to look at this
uh
at this guy here what i'm doing is i'm
i'm taking my uh i'm taking my
algorithm here with my
quasi-approximation algorithm
and i'm comparing to the guy the mean
field guy
but with both of them have a step size
that's what's different than traditional
stochastic approximation
analysis i use the same step size for
each
i look at the difference between the two
and i divide by the step size
so a of t is going to zero so if this is
bounded
i'll get a rate of a of 18.
okay that's the hope if z is bounded i
get my rate of convergence and i get the
constants because the
rate of convergence you know theta of t
is equal to theta bar t
uh plus uh ztat
you know and that's going to zero if i
so if i know a bound on
on zt then i have a really good thing
here
and balancing rate of convergence here
is is much easier
as i'll explain well maybe i won't
why this z explain would take another
lecture because i'd have to give a
lecture on
on um on the app enough theory
for um non-linear systems and i don't
have time for that but uh
um but this you can all guess right this
is much easier to stand
um than this thing here all right
it satisfies the differential equation
so the derivative of z to respect the
time
looks just like what we started with
except linearized
and plus some crazy noise over here
so what this crazy noise is
is a difference between the vector field
defining the quasi stochastic
approximation algorithm
and the vector field here for the
deterministic algorithm
all right so that's noise
and and this is pretty isn't it so i get
this additional term here
um which is the derivative of the log of
the game
and this is just a chain rule it's
trivial but it's
it's so damn tight under very mild
conditions
you get this result that this rt here
is this plus this and it's not just
little it you can get a very crisp
bound on on how on that error term
all right so that's step two
all right you're all awake and then um
in particular let's just stick to these
special cases
you know the standard thing you look at
in stochastic approximation is
like a constant over one plus two to the
rho
then r t turns out to be greater over
one plus t
i mean yeah rho over one plus t plus
it's a little of a t
and here's where you see the big
discrepancies
if rho is less than one
then um
[Music]
well i should do it here if we're always
less than one then one every one plus t
is going to zero super fast um compared
to the other term
so it's it's negligible in terms of at
least in first order
ideas of rates um but if rho equals one
then rt and eighty are the same
magnitude and that's that's the reason
you get this
this bigger matrix in the case of uh
using or equals one
okay so really it really helps to
explain things
all right and then all right
you still awake what time is it
then you make a change of variables i'll
i'll explain what this crazy thing is in
a moment
it's basically this noise
it's what's the integral of the noise
i'll define it actually but
let's forget it for now um basically
what i'm going to do is i
i want to my goal is to take this and
bring it to the
other side and doing that i get some
approximations but they're not too bad
and so with this change of variables yt
also satisfies an ode and
this now is zero mean
and this is a constant
all right and then this is just an
additive term
big deal i don't need to emphasize that
okay all right so this is this is just
from here here's again a bit of algebra
once i've defined this you know which i
don't have a definition but
the big thing is that we can get a rate
of conversions
on this really easily with a with a rate
that yt is basically a constant and
therefore we've identified c2
so zt is just equal to the thing i
haven't defined
plus a constant
okay and and we can sharpen this a lot
you know we won't have time today but we
can discuss it later
okay yeah so the amazing conclusion is
is that
we have this result
that uh the parameters at theta t is
theta star
um you know plus the step size real time
is this
um and here i can finally give you the
definitions
so um
so this weird thing here
it's an integral of this zero mean
process
all right because we know this we know
this is bounded
and it's we're assuming this is an
assumption
that this poisson's equation solution
exists
but but in the you'll see the lecture
notes it's valid into very minor
minor conditions so this is just a
a sinusoidal signal basic i mean a
periodic signal is
almost periodic signal and then there's
a constant so we get this really
thing and i can and again we'll discuss
it later you can sharpen this quite a
bit
um and so uh this bias because we're
doing quasi
uh we're doing you know um kiefer
walford stuff
but it's avoid epsilon squared or
something and
to your point job about do we want to
compute things exactly
we don't you know so i wouldn't mind a
constant step size so i'm
i'm looking at managing step size to get
some really tight uh
understanding in practice i might use a
very small constant step size maybe not
you know
we'll discuss that as well so the bias i
don't think is a big issue
now here's a fun fact anybody out there
like eric you must be out there i don't
know eric colleen um
many people out there saying yeah just
do rupert poliak averaging
so basically you take the output of the
algorithm
with less than one say rho equals a half
and then you just average it that's the
definition of polio
uh grouping averaging well guess what it
fails
um it fails because of this damn thing
here
it works if and only if the strange y
bar thing is zero
and i don't know what the hell this
thing is
i can give you cases where it's zero but
in general it's not
it's a very non-local thing
yeah so um so sorry you can't use your
um
i don't think it's going to work for
quasi-gradient descent and gel
so uh it's that hat there that makes it
non-local
you know the f-hat means it depends on
the behavior of the system
far from the equilibrium so that's
that's what happens so that's fun this
is this is a few weeks old in a way
and a month old i'm really excited about
it
um so again um yeah i've got a minute
so some refinements and warnings now
global one
i haven't given you conditions for
convergence for any of the state of work
you can you can find in the book chapter
lipstick's continuity of f
is really critical in the analysis and
all
um and for example
if you look at this algorithm which i
used to love
it has almost the same f bar
um as uh as the other algorithm i
presented
if if [ __ ] she has zero mean
you're like a mixture of sinus swords
you know zero temporal meaning um but
l is going to typically be strongly
convex
so in that case l is not going to be
global ellipses continuous
and so the theory falls apart none of
what i said is true
you might be able to get some local
theory but i can't you know i'm not
going to try
now at first i didn't realize that and i
did experiments
this is mountain car by the way i'll
explain it next lecture
i i compared this algorithm
with you know with the sort of kefir
wall for which equivalent
where you put an ied noise with the same
variance in quotes
and with the stochastic algorithm
see i did a thousand independent trials
you got this incredibly just noise every
run looked different
while with the quasi algorithm it was
consistently converging
close to the minimum after only 5 000
samples
because i was doing oily schemes
sampling every second
and there's a lack of it doesn't always
converge to the same thing
but it converges to the valley the
objective function is flat
this light blue thing is the objective
function
and so after 5000 samples it's dead on
giving you something right in that tiny
region where it's almost optimal so it's
just i'm very excited about how
well this performs in some experiments
i've done
okay so conclusions don't introduce
volatility if you don't have to
uh what's the best way to do translation
is ask the beginning of the lecture
i think people in quasi monte carlo
would love to help so why not let them
also people in numerical analyst
analysis looking at differential
equations
we should bring them in you know more
than merrier
um applications to constrained
optimizations is something we're working
on
with friends at nrl in particular um and
in particular what i just talked about
in the last lecture
you know we have a constrained
optimization problem there um
and applications are always the next uh
next thing
now what's really funny is that an
interest in
kefa wolfowitz was reborn two years ago
at the at the 2018 program um
[Music]
when paniatus with greek last name
and chabad don't ask me to pronounce
your last name either um he grabbed at
ethan and i
and we set to work trying to get a
better understanding of rate of
conversions to kiefer wolfowitz
um so uh it was really it was really
cool i mean that program was just
life-changing
thank you simon that was just one thing
it was it was awesome talking to
pontiacs
but i give up and the quasi theory is so
damn simple
i want to dive into that and i'm going
to let somebody else
uh extend the theory for stochastic
algorithms um
that's what i'm saying here some of the
ideas that i
laid out to you i bet could help to
improve the rate theory for
stochastic algorithms but again i'm
going to leave that to somebody else
yeah that's it
questions cool uh
thank you uh so sharon was asking away
uh was funny was asking about this
averaging exactly this slide yeah
this is something like that everything
that you're talking about here
well no well oh yeah this is this is
polyacryl republic averaging so you'll
be probably
averaging um the way it's defined is you
you take a very high gain algorithm
you know so they had more restrictive
consumptions on row
is one example so so the
the high gain so again the row is right
there
means that this is so if rho is small
it means high gain you're pushing up
18. it's big
yeah um yeah i'm taking something small
raising it to the grow power yeah
and so and so that that means that means
high volatility
okay and so rupert poliak proved that if
for stochastic algorithms that if you
just do that
say okay i'll have high volatility but
i'll average at the end
you get the optimal now you get the
optimal rate of convergence
and the optimal constants in the rate
it's absolutely mind-boggling
in practice it doesn't work very well
often
because the rate of convergence of clt
is sometimes very slow
uh i think there ways to fix that so but
in practice
it hasn't been very popular because of
that but for the
the term is the case it actually fails
because of this residual constant
um it's because our objective is strong
stronger
they're trying to get the clt in the
usable sense i'm trying to get one of
her t conversions right
and so that's that's the reason it fails
yeah
um yeah i guess sharon's uh point was
actually that
uh maybe there's something called tail
averaging where you put higher weight
on uh that
that's that's that's what i was going to
say in fact if you look at my lecture
notes that's all i say
i the only reason i i presented this
was so easy to write it down so so
theoretically this has the same variance
as tail averaging
but in practice no way tail averaging
kicks ass
you know it's it's just it's amazing how
much better it is
and the experiments i've done it's all
tail aperture so i take the last 20
say or something uh-huh
so roshan had a question on uh this
score that i we're trying to convey
uh i think it was it mostly relates to
the previous lecture
um so the question was whether the ode
approach to stochastic approximation can
also recover the ideas from online
learning and online optimization like
mirror descent regularizers whatnot
it's a bit open-ended
um whether i guess
the elaboration is whether you know
these ideas
are able to the continuous time and that
is able to
recover the performance guarantees that
usually you get for the online
from the online learning uh literature
i think it was what i was also poking at
previously
yeah i don't know the thing is that here
you know a lot of what i'm doing here is
showing that the
stochastic algorithm and the
deterministic algorithm
couple so fast that it's not even random
and um
[Music]
and but only because i designed the
deterministic algorithm
carefully you know like i mentioned if i
use the wrong gain it's not true
so if i design my non-quasi
pure mean derivative thing properly
i automatically get incredibly fast rate
of convergence
and i wish i had time well maybe i i
mean
you've got your theta star right
and then i'm going to draw an epsilon
ball around that
sum or delta whatever and i have an
initial condition here
theta 0 all right and i've got my
deterministic guy
my my theta dot equals f bar
of theta and i put bars on that just to
oh do i need my game
now there's two properties there's
one how long to reach the bowl
what's cool is that this is just a time
change
of the original ode
so they have enough to give it gives you
answers
you know so we can get balance on the
time to reach this ball he's in the up
enough theory
right and then within the bowl
we have pristine rate results
great bounce
christine i'm just excited everyone i'm
not bragging
because it's so you know what is it
something's very new
you you smile a lot so i'm not it's not
arrogance it's happiness
um it's the word pristine sounds totally
arrogant and pretentious but i
i but it's true that you'll see the the
results i've given to you i haven't
given you the details
you get really really nice results in in
this
region of attraction for the
deterministic guy
not for the stochastic guy you know so
lyapunov theory tells you this is
invariant
for this invariant this this ball
um this is an invariant set so for the
for the theta bar said you can never
leave it
and the fact you can never leave it is
how you get such
a tight bounds
so to answer your question i think that
you can get
a lot of success by first looking at the
idealization of the e and then
once you understand that well enough go
to the stochastic or whatever you know
the noisy version
yeah so there's no way to prove it's
absorbing for the original thing it's
for this
deterministic guy that's sort of an
answer
i was also wondering about whether there
is any connection to i remember that
there was a time in the 90s where we
people were trying to work out
conditions for stochastic approximation
that were based on deterministic
analysis
like i think diane or urbanium or
oh sure okay that's the thing but they
but they were
i mean how do you pronounce his name
anyway he was mainly
extending the theory just beautiful ways
of conceptualizing really difficult
problems
you know where f is not not lipschitz
it's not smooth not anything
and it's a really nice dynamical systems
theory to
he has his great lecture notes on that
um
[Music]
and diana i don't know the diana
reference i know diane but i don't know
what you're referring to
um it's been a why i've
looked at this laser so i have the top
of my head but i see that there is
something called deterministic analysis
of stochastic approximation algorithms i
can dig
up the reference later yeah
i remember that like they were talking
about
uh sufficient conditions for the noise
sequence to hoard which is not noise
anymore but
this deterministic perturbation oh yeah
yeah you always see
that's and that's a yeah yeah yeah oh
that's absolutely so
um um yeah but but
i i yeah that's right which is really a
good way to go is because
instead of assuming its idea mar or
martingale
put conditions on the noise um but all
all the theory i'm aware of is geared
towards making sure
it's uh acceptable when you go to a uh
iid setting or whatever and i'm going
the other really i don't want it to be
acceptable
because i'm trying to get this one over
t rated convergence yeah yeah i see that
but
my goals are different that's all um
yeah
i should have said that the prior work
i'm aware of is in finance
i i forgot to mention that i'm not in
rates of convergence but i'm using
um like sine waves you can again you can
find in the references
um is there
so so you also mentioned this uh so this
is uh the fair wolf of it uh
it's like the two-point
approximation of the gradient psa
and then you were talking about the one
point approximation
and if you do the approximation you can
do the taylor
expansion to a higher degree and i think
that maybe one crucial fact here
is that you have the same noise plugged
into two places
yeah that you can study each other um
or same perturbation in this case um
which uh is going to be challenging
reinforcement learning
right uh-huh yeah yeah good point so
that so that's right
i mean if you ever stimulate
that's a good point yeah um oh
i'll give an example next hour where
it's not a big deal
you know but you write in general would
be a big deal um
this is one of the big reasons you can
get the faster it because you can reuse
the
same perturbation twice and make two
measurements at least
oh no no well the theory is totally
general
although it's the lipsticks continuity
because my the theorem i gave
is nothing to do with anything it's
totally general
it doesn't require kefir wolf words or
anything oh okay okay
oh yeah sorry if i didn't make that
clear oh no so this was just an example
um but but this but oh i'm sorry i
should have made that clearer i didn't
realize that
now this entire theory part was for
anything
um this theorem here this theorem here
is for anything
okay yeah i mean the assumptions are
really mild um
okay cool yeah i need a little function
of something
to make sure i get in a region of
attraction and i need the linearization
that's really crucial you know
i need smoothness of theta star
okay everyone left oh no
all right good so the next collection
will be lighter
i think it'll be a lot of history but
it'll be fun history
and some examples of how to apply these
ideas to
um to the mountain car
it's a fun last lecture
all right uh so let's take a quick break
and and we come back in 20 minutes